نتابع واياكم هذه الصور لاستقبال الرئيس
الاوكراني همم فلوديمير سيلين سكي صور همم
نتابعها الان لاستقبال الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي ميرسيلنسكي لرئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيس هناك اليوم في همم العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف اذا هذه صور نتبعها الان
لاستقبال الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي رئيسه وزراء
بريطانيا الجديد ريشه سوناك والذي اجتمع
به كما نشاهد مع عدد من القيادات ربما
العسكريه الاوكرانيه مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الجديد همم شيء هناك في همم
زياره الاولى التي يقوم همم بها اذا الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف همم ربما كانت
الزياره الاخيره لمسؤول همم
كبير على نفس المستوى كانتر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني
السابق كانت في هذا العام ايضا الان نتابع
هذه همم الصور هذه
الاوربما
المحادثات التي تمخض عنها نتائج مهمه تحدث
عنها طبعا بهذا الشكل رئيس ال- همم الرئيس
الاوكراني فلوديمير زينسكي وقال بانهم
نقشوا عدد من الملفات وهناك نتائج مهمه
الرشحت عن هذه همم
مقابله او هذا الاجتماع بين الرئيس
الاوكراني في الودميرسيلتك رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الجديد المعين ريشي سونيك